j'ai une dernière question j'archer si
vous le voulez bien on vous a vu en
grande conversation avec Mick jeger la
semaine dernière à Versailles et des des
personnes se demandent ce que vous vous
disiez avec le rocker à ce moment-là à
Versailles ça a fait beaucoup de buzz
sur les réseaux sociaux est-ce que vous
pouvez nous confier ce que vous disiez à
ce moment-là en tous les cas nous avons
beaucoup évoqué le valde Loire car il a
une résidence dans le Val de Loire et je
lui expliqué qu'il y avait une partie de
l'âme française et que c'était une âme
française souvent apaisée ce qui
n'empêche pas d'avoir beaucoup de rythme
le long de la Loire voilà ça vous a
amusé c c voilà c'était un bon moment et
être le voisin de son épouse était un
excellent moment aussi voilà très bien
et bien merci Monsieur Larché pour cette
réaction au micro de public sén merci
beaucoup merci merci beaucoup Quentin
pour cette interview de Gérard Larcher
voilà juste après sa réélection Gérard
Larcher qui a donc été réélu président
du Sénat avec 218 voix à l'instant il a
été acclamé par
l'